- Good afternoon, everyone.
Good day, good evening.
Wherever you're joining us from.
I'm Ann Kurth
and the Dean of the
Yale School of Nursing.
And I'm really delighted
to welcome each of you
to the Global Health Conversation series
sponsored by the Yale Institute
for Global Health, YIGH.
The series is a venue for
our community to learn from
and connect with innovative
leaders in global health.
In addition to YIGH,
we are indebted to the
George Herbert Walker, Jr.
Lecture in International Studies
at the Whitney and Betty MacMillan Center
for International and Area Studies at Yale
for co-sponsoring the series,
including today's event.
I'm so pleased to be able to
welcome the over 700 people
who registered for today's
event, including faculty,
students, and alumni of Yale University,
colleagues at the UN Development Program
and at Permanent Missions
to the UN in New York
and the general public.
It's a pleasure to be with you all today.
As we are all seeing more
and more and experiencing
earth's life sustaining
ecosystems are being undermined,
threatening human health, other
species health, development
and survival.
While we have seen increases
in the lifespan and declines
in child mortality and
notable reductions in poverty,
these advances are being
undermined by climate change,
deforestation, loss of arable
land, freshwater depletion,
ocean acidification and pollution.
Today's conversation will
focus on the critical issue
of Planetary Health, which
stresses the urgent need
to better understand
relationships between these
global scale impacts
and population health,
and to develop strategies
and policies to lessen
these impacts, repair natural systems
and maintain the planet in
a state that is conducive
to optimal population health.
Planetary health has become
an increasingly important area
at Yale, with a variety of
initiatives across the campus.
Through YIGH, we have recently launched
a planetary health network,
which brings together
faculty members from across
the university who are passionate
about planetary health,
to collaborate on research projects
and knowledge sharing initiatives.
Please look to the YIGH
website, if you're interested
in learning more or joining this network.
In addition, the
university has launched the
Planetary Solutions Project
which draws on Yale's repository
of world-class knowledge,
innovation and leadership,
to address human caused
environmental change and crises.
Building on this effort, we
are so pleased to have with us
today, Achim Steiner,
Administrator of the
UN Development Program.
For nearly three decades,
Administrator Steiner
has been a global leader
on sustainable development,
climate resilience and
international cooperation.
To formally introduce Administrator
Steiner, I'll now turn
to my colleague, Dr. LaRon Nelson.
- Hello everyone.
My name is LaRon Nelson
and I'm the Associate
in Global Affairs and Planetary Health
at the Yale School of Nursing.
Today I am pleased to be joined
by my fellow co-moderator,
Dr. Robert Dubrow,
Professor of Epidemiology
at the Yale School of Public Health
and the Faculty Director
of the Yale Center
on Climate Change and Health.
Thanks for being here today Rob.
Rob Dubrow and I are
also the co-leads of the
Yale Institute for Global
Health Planetary Health Network.
And we are excited that today's
event will spark new ideas
and interest on this
critically important issue.
It is my pleasure to introduce
today's distinguished guest,
Achim Steiner,
Administrator of the United
Nations Development Program.
Over his entire career, he has
worked tirelessly to champion
sustainable development, green economy
and international cooperation.
And has been a vocal
advocate of the 2030 Agenda
and the Sustainable Development Goals.
Administrator Steiner has
served across the United Nation
system looking at global
challenges through the
sustainable development lens.
Between 2006 and 2016, he led the
United Nations Environment
Program, the UN's leading
environmental authority
that sets the global
environmental agenda.
In 2017 he was elected
by the United Nations
General Assembly to head the
United Nations Development
Program, which works with
170 countries to support
poverty eradication
and inclusive society.
Achim Steiner had previously
held other notable positions
including Director of
Oxford Martin School,
Director General of
the International Union
for the Conservation of
Nature and Secretary General
of the World Commission on Dams.
In December of last year,
the United Nations Development Program
launched its Human
Development Report 2020.
Which lays out a stark
choice for world leaders.
"Take bold steps to reduce
the immense pressure
that is being exerted on the environment
and the natural world or
humanity's progress will stall."
The report argues that as
people and the planet enter
an entirely new geological
epoch, the Anthropocene
or the age of humans, it
is time for all countries
to redesign their path to progress,
while fully accounting for
the dangerous pressures,
humans put on the planet and dismantled
the growth imbalances
of power and opportunity
that prevent change.
During today's conversation,
I look forward to discussing
the reports and the important
issue of planetary health.
Please join me in welcoming
Administrator Steiner.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much Dean
Kurt, Dean LaRon Nelson,
Professor Dubrow.
I assume that this is where
I simply take off and jump in
unless somebody stops me.
And let me begin by thanking you all for
this wonderful invitation, the
opportunity to spend an hour
and a half with you and
some of your faculty
and others who are
interested in this topic of
"Planetary Health."
And I want to thank both the
Dean and President Nelson for
the very kind introduction
because what in a sense prompted
I think us to focus on this
issue of planets, people
and prosperity and planetary
health has really come
into focus, particularly
through our world of UNDP
through the Human Development
Report we published for 2020.
And for those of you who
may not be so familiar,
UNDP is the United Nations
Development Program.
It's at the heart of the
UN development system.
It's the entity that
works in 170 countries
on the major development
issues of our time.
But it's also an
organization that obviously
with the experience it's
assembled from so many different
frontiers of development across the world,
tries to sometimes bring
into focus the challenges
and perhaps the horizons
against which we need to think
about the future of development.
And so the topic of "Planetary
health" and the theme
of our 2020 Human Development
Report coincide very neatly.
Because they both
recognize that we are at an
inflection point.
And that inflection point
comes down to something very
common sense like, you
sometimes have to wonder why
it took us so long to
realize that human health
and environmental health
are inextricably linked.
And everybody knows this from a kind of
locational experience.
Pollution is something
that we have known for
hundreds of years, and
we know that pollution
and environmental condition
clearly affects human health.
But over time, we have
also begun to realize that
it's not just a locational issue,
it used to be an issue of
urban geography to those of you
who maybe have studied
geography in your lives,
where if you look particularly
in the United Kingdom
at the settlement patterns
and urbanization patterns
the wealthy always lived up
wind of an industrial factory
or industrial infrastructure.
And the poor lived down wind.
Already there you saw the
impact of pollution, inequality,
and quality of life, including
the impact on the health
of people, very clearly
manifested in a way that
today really has taken
on a planetary dimension.
And if I may just fast
forward a little bit
and take another example of pollution
that already 40 years ago
began to preoccupy us.
Ozone depleting substances,
destroying a very thin film
of ozone, the ozone layer
around our planet earth.
And our recognition that
we had to phase out these
ozone depleting substances
in order to avoid
what was already
beginning to be manifestly
a planetary health problem,
a hole in the ozone layer,
increased number in cancer,
skin cancers, premature death.
And so the toll, the numbers
and the empirical evidence
continue to mount about how environmental,
not just destruction, but
also environmental impacts,
clearly were linked to human wellbeing.
Fast-forward a little bit,
because this is a sort of
common sense entry point,
but today we live in a time
and Professor Nelson just alluded to it,
We have taken this notion
of living in the age
of the Anthropocene as a way
of trying to re conceptualize
quite how significant
the impact of humans is.
Anthropocene, the age of
humans is a simple way
of expressing an immensely
complex set of changes
and developments that are underway.
But using the term
Anthropocene, and it is not yet
an accepted one in the geological
sense of an age or an era
like the Holocene, but
scientists and bodies
are currently debating
whether indeed the notion
of living in the age of the
Anthropocene after the Holocene
does make sense.
And what it really implies is two things.
One, the nature and scale
of the impact of humans
on the planet has become
geologically traceable.
We are now the dominant
species on this planet.
We are changing its
atmosphere, its biosphere.
We are changing the composition
of the quality of water,
the quality of air,
and many other elements
that signals to us that
this is a qualitative
and quantitative different
dimension in which we need
to think about the
presence of homo sapiens,
the human species so
to speak on the planet.
And to some this is obviously
very much a narrative
associated with the doomsday scenario,
but let me very quickly try
and counter that notion.
Yes, it is a way of understanding
quite how significant
our collective impact
is on this planet today
and by implication and by consequences
on future generations.
But it is also a way of trying
to focus on the fact that
we have choices.
Never in human history before
have we had the wealth,
the science, the
knowledge, the technology,
the possibilities of
choosing different pathways
and therefore living in
the age of the Anthropocene
is not inevitably a doomsday scenario,
on the contrary, it is an era of choices
and choices with consequences
that are intergenerational.
Now very quickly, fast forward
to how we have measured
human progress.
Because part of the planetary
health notion, people, planet,
prosperity, has basically
being this very simplistic way
that essentially its through
economics, through money,
through wealth, through
gross domestic product,
per capita GDP, that we
have spent the better part
of 100 years of measuring human
progress, human development.
And it was that led in about 30 years ago,
UNDP to challenge this
notion that the best way
to measure progress and
development was to do so
through this economic narrow lens.
That's when the Human Development
Report was first conceived
of by very inspiring and
forward looking economists,
Professor Amartya Sen, Mahbub
ul Haq and many others
who came up with the
human development index.
And in its simplest form,
it was a way of expanding
the lens, introducing health and education
as additional parameters
for measuring human progress
and very deeply rooted in
the notion of capabilities,
capabilities to succeed as a human being.
Now, we still as a world,
continued to measure progress
almost exclusively through this GDP lens.
And it is one that has led us
essentially to the point where
today you could argue we
are truly missing the point,
namely that people, planet and prosperity,
have a far more intricate relationship
and decisions need to evolve
far more rapidly in order to
ensure sure that human
wellbeing and the corollary
of planetary wellbeing,
of planetary health
need to be managed in sync.
We need to measure progress differently.
We need to take different decisions.
And this is why in 2020, our
Human Development Report shows
the new frontier, the next
frontier in human development
as being related precisely to this issue.
We introduced a new planet readjusted
human development index
that try to capture
the health of the planet
through the impacts that
we are having as humans
combined with a traditional
human development index.
It's an experimental index.
We have put it out there
for the world to consider
what we believe it is perhaps
the best way in which we can
currently give expression to
this notion planetary health
and it's links to human health.
Now and its consequences,
and I'll end with that,
is a simple recognition, and
Bobby Kennedy once put it
very simply, he says that, "GDP
measures everything in short
except that which makes life worthwhile."
And it is that search for
a way in which we can take
a common sense realization,
an intuitive understanding
that underpins that
notion of planetary health
and translate it into measurable
and empirically validated
foundations.
Because that is how we make public policy.
That is how we trade off
choices in different contexts.
And much of what UNDP does
today, not least in the midst
of a COVID-19 crisis, is to
help countries conceive of
a development pathway out of this crisis,
building forward better.
Now it's easily proclaimed.
It is easily stated.
How do you do it?
You have to make policy choices about
the fiscal policy
systems, taxation systems,
because here is the first distortion,
our markets are not operating rationally.
They subsidize things that harm us
and essentially harm ultimately prosperity
and tax the good decisions
that people take.
This is the taxation system
of the early 21st century.
We tax labor through high income taxes
but we hardly tax pollution.
It's not rational in this age.
And it is fundamental to
understanding why we have come
to a point where planetary
health has become
such a challenge.
We need to look also at
the way that inequality
intersects with planetary health.
The fact that research
showed us some years ago
that when lead was still
being put into petrol
with the argument that
essentially that was a price
we had to pay for affordable mobility,
it was the poor who lived by the roadsides
of the main highways that
were most effected by lead
in petrol.
And it was the children
of poor people who had far
higher levels of lead in
their bodies than children
of wealthier families.
Because they lived further
away from the highways.
They had gardens, they
lived in leafier suburbs.
Simple illustrations of how inequality
and environmental impacts
and human health interface.
Let me end by just saying,
'cause I look forward very much
to the questions and the
discussions that we have,
that in a world of the 21st
century, in thinking about
the future of development,
which is so much the focus
of UNDP's work today and that
of the United Nations system
in helping a very unequal
world and a very stressed world
to find together a better way forward,
using the Sustainable Development
Goals that many of you
will have heard, not as
some metric, but rather
as a compass on which we can
together address a reset,
a recalibration of the
yardsticks of human progress.
And ultimately enable us to
realize a very simple fact,
prosperity is about people
and not about money.
We measure prosperity in monetary terms
but actually what we really mean is,
are people able to fulfill
their aspirations in life?
And so to demonetize to some extent,
not to ignore that dimension
but to demonetize it
to some extent and to compliment
it with an understanding
of how much people therefore
also depend on the planet
for their wellbeing and
how the way we consume
and produce and exercise
our economic choices,
ultimately shapes the nature of our planet
and its ability to sustain us,
is at the heart of rethinking
people, planet and prosperity
in our age.
Thank you so much.
And President Nelson back to you.
- Hi.
So actually this is Robert Dubrow,
so it's back to me.
So yeah.
Thanks Administrators
Steiner for some very
insightful comments.
And building on those comments,
I wanted to ask the first question.
So I and Dr. Nelson will
ask a couple of questions
and then we're gonna open
it up to the audience.
So my first question is, and
you you dealt to some degree
with this already.
So I was wondering if you could elaborate,
what is the scope and scale of
human pressures on the planet
and importantly do the social
imbalances and inequality
contribute to the problem?
- Well, I gave you a couple
of parameters already,
but just to give you a
sense, let me, for instance
give you a couple of more
indicators of the scale
for example.
If you realize that the
total mass of things
humans have made like
buildings, roads, bottle tops,
plastic bags now exceeds the
total mass of all living things
on our planet.
It gives you one sense of
the anthropogenic impact
we have had or this sheer
scale of what we have.
And there are some
wonderful other analogies
about chicken bones for example.
A few people will
realize that chickens are
the most mass produced,
consumable livestock in the world.
And if you were to add
up all the chicken bones
ever consumed, extraordinary
mountains would be formed
on planet earth.
But let me also give you
a sense of quiet how dark
some of these statistics
have become particularly
in the last 100 years.
We have destroyed well over
50% of the world's wetlands
in just half a century,
in the name of progress,
in the name of development, in the name of
useless environmental assets
that are not being put into
productive use.
We have dammed most of the
world's rivers with the argument
that the ingenuity, human
ingenuity of building dams
to produce electricity,
irrigate lands always outweighs
the ingenuity of nature
that has given us these
extraordinary riverine and
hydrological ecosystems
that have such extraordinary functions
in our planetary context,
but also in terms of
humanity's survival.
And water is another very
good example and metaphor
through which to look at
the kind of situations
we have created for ourselves.
In a country like Australia
today, the Murray-Darling basin
is a river basin where most
of the water is now traded.
It is traded and it is no
longer used for farming
but in fact, farmers
trade their water rights
to the urban city municipalities
in order to ensure
that these municipalities
have enough water to
provide drinking water
to the urban population.
We are reaching in so
many aspects and also
parts of the world, planetary boundaries.
It's a concept that has
emerged in recent years.
And I think provides us
with a very useful way
of understanding what is
the boundary condition
after which you're no longer dealing
with the planets ingenious
systems of producing what we need
to survive in it, but you are
depleting the capital stock,
so to speak and you're
destroying the capability
of nature to sustain us.
And another horrendous
statistic is that roughly 70%
seven, zero of the world's
wildlife may have been lost
in the past 50 years.
Add to that climate change that
we are just a few years away
from passing the point at which
carbon emissions accumulated
in the atmosphere are going
to move beyond the point
of no return in terms of a
1.5 degree warming scenario.
For generations, probably
hundreds of years,
people will no longer have
even the option of trying to
get back to a world that maybe has warming
below 1.5 degrees.
No, it is then essentially
a reality out of control.
These are some of the
parameters within which I think
we can begin to comprehend
the scope and scale of change.
And that is why I often say
we are the first generation
of the Anthropocene, where truly
we have began to understand
that we are changing the
atmosphere and the biosphere
on this planet, inconceivable
to our grandparents,
a reality and a very stark
one to our children already.
- Administrator Steiner,
I wasn't prepared for that
chicken bone example.
I have to say, I feel
personally responsible
for that particular challenge.
- You have your work cut out.
- In the Human Development 2020 Report,
it was stark how it laid out,
how calamities are really
the product of this concept
of people and planet
being out of sync.
Talk to us about how
COVID-19 is an example
of this imbalance between
human and planetary health
and also what have we learned from it
and how can we be prepared for
the next pandemic, calamity?
- You know to me personally,
the pandemic has been
a stark reminder of something
that maybe 20 years ago
really led me to focus on
the link between environment
and development or environment
and human wellbeing
in ways that maybe when I was
studying at the university,
as a development economist,
had not really been
at the forefront of my mind.
And that was the realization
that in so many ways,
at this point in time, we
are confronted with choices
that yes, in some respects
still must be based
on imperfect knowledge.
But this is where I sometimes
have often struggled
with the debates about climate change.
Because there's this notion
that we will only decide
to do something when we
have perfect knowledge,
goes against everything
that we have learned
in human history.
And who ever in life has
the privilege of having
perfect knowledge and foresight
in order to take a decision?
And I think it is that conundrum
in which we find ourselves
namely the necessity to act
with sufficient information
to make us more cautionary
about what comes next
and yet not having a guarantee
that the solutions we have
will work.
COVID-19 first of all is
a perfect illustration
of the latter.
So many decisions have to
be taken in a number of days
so often we got it wrong.
So often we paid a price
which in hindsight you ask
yourself, "how could this have happened?"
The second big lesson is, I
think we need to realize that
preparedness is not a luxury.
And if you just take the numbers today,
the cost of this pandemic alone
is about 500 times as much
as a pandemic prevention
measures combination
would have cost us if we
had taken them in time.
And probably that number
is an underestimate.
Because we did not take
this thing seriously
despite the fact that we
had SARS, we had Ebola,
we had enough illustrations
about how zoonotic diseases
can jump from the animal
kingdom so to speak,
into human bodies.
This is not something that has
happened for the first time
to us, it has happened to us
time and again in history.
But now we are in the 21st century.
And here, I think there is
the added dimension that with
travel, with global trade, but
also with the interdependence
that we have built up, we
are so much more vulnerable,
physically, economically and socially.
And I think it is this
combination of realities
that I think is making us
all reflect far more deeply
about what will life be
like following COVID-19.
And let's always remind
ourselves that we are still
in the midst of this crisis.
Yes, some countries are now
vaccinating ahead of others
but just the vaccination dilemma
is already an illustration
of how difficult we're finding it to act
as a global community, when
we know that we're gonna
lose this battle against the virus
if we cannot vaccinate everyone.
And yet look at the statistical
reality of who is getting
vaccinated right now and who is not.
This is one of the
illustrations of what we mean by
acting against our own interests.
This is not rational, and this
is the price we are paying
for not taking the notion
of resilience seriously.
And the relationship between
nature and human wellbeing
is not only, I think illustrated
in this instance by a virus
that has moved into our
lives in such a brutal way,
it is the realization that
so much of what has happened
in the last 50 to 100 years in particular,
because that's where all the
curves went up exponentially,
deforestation, pollution,
destruction of wetlands,
et cetera, soil fertility
that is being lost,
ocean acidification.
These are all drivers of
greater environmental change
and ultimately vulnerability.
And I think the more we
are able to see these
systems interact, the more we recognize
that we are actually
entering into an age of
extreme vulnerability and even more so
of a lack of preparedness.
And therefore resilience
becomes more elusive
rather than something that we have built.
At a moment in time when
science technology and wealth
for that matter, would
have suggested otherwise.
- Yeah, thank you, Administrator Steiner.
I wanted to turn to how
we actually effect change.
So the question is how can
we encourage policy makers
and legislators to consider the
impacts of planetary health?
How can we incentivize
positive change and innovations
at all levels, at the local
domestic, regional and global?
- Again, at the risk
of over simplification,
but as a first starter to
respond to your question.
I think there are a number
of drivers that ultimately
will determine how a
society makes choices.
And the first one has to be
informed and empowered citizens.
I think whether even if
you're living in a more
autocratic regime or you're
living in the ideal democracy,
which probably is also
an illusive aspiration
perhaps in the minds of many,
informed and empowered citizens
are ultimately the base
upon which you can both
transact and develop
different policy choices.
And I think one of the great
things about time is that
if you, even if I look
at the generations that
are now coming after us, kids
who are five, 10, 15 year old
today,
they live in an age where
information and the ability
to understand more about what
is happening to the world,
not just around you, where
we absolutely grew up
still in a very isolated
family or rural community
might've found ourselves in
the sixties or even seventies,
today for many children around the world,
understanding that there
is a world out there
and that they are part of it,
come so much more naturally.
And I think therein lies,
one of my reasons for being
an optimist, because I
do believe that informed
and empowered citizens do act differently.
And just take the example
of Fridays For Future.
And here we are in a moment
in time where 13, 14,
15 year olds have essentially taken charge
of the most central challenge
of our time, climate change.
Not only has it opened the
eyes and opened conversations
in virtually every country
in a different way,
they are leading the debate,
and they are leading it
with a clarity of purpose
and understanding that
I must say I'm sometimes
envious when I compare my daily life,
sitting in the United Nations conferences
and looking at how they
sometimes try to transact
despite what we know.
But this is, the second part.
And herein lies, I think
a critical understanding,
our economies are foundation
to what sustains us.
It drives our ability to
ultimately have employment,
have food, access to electricity,
healthcare, and so on.
So how our economy sends
signals and in which direction,
it encourages consumption and
production or discourages it,
is critical.
One taxation and fiscal policy,
we still live in an age where,
as I mentioned earlier on,
we subsidize things that
we know based on science
and evidence are harmful, but
because of legacy interests,
because of the inertia in our economies,
because of economic power,
being invested in perhaps
a few have a lot to gain
from the status quo.
We are not acting on knowledge.
We are keeping an economic system going,
that essentially has to shift.
Whether you call it a green economy,
a more equitable economy,
that social contract
in which governments essentially
shape the economic rules
of the game needs to evolve.
And fiscal policy, taxation,
fossil fuel subsidies,
these are just some egregious examples
of where we need to focus on.
And it ultimately comes down
to how financial markets
will view the future.
Financial markets, I think are
often viewed as this sort of,
untamable dinosaur or monster.
But really financial
markets at their simplest
are fairly mercenary.
Where you can make money,
you will go and make money.
So what is it that makes
it so difficult for us
at this crucial moment in
time to also incentivize
financial markets to invest differently?
To invest in tomorrow's
economy, rather than
in yesterday's economy.
And here is the great debate of our time.
How much does the state,
how do governments step in,
how much do governments also
compensate for the fact that
markets are not very good at transacting
in the interest of the public good?
It's not that they are
automatically at cross purposes
with the public good, but
the public good clearly down
right now, demands that we get to a zero,
net zero emissions world by 2050.
And there is no one who
has yet proven to me,
that markets left to their own devices,
will do this in time.
Which is why regulatory
and public policy signals
need to accelerate the pace of change,
give rise to new markets.
And frankly speaking, we
are already seeing it happen
where we put the right measures in place.
Renewable energy.
We're in the midst of a
renewable energy revolution.
It is transforming our energy systems.
And hundreds of years of
relying on fossil fuels
are probably, 20 to 30 years
down the line of becoming
really anachronism.
And that's how quickly we can shift,
for example on something
like fossil fuels,
the lifeblood of our 20th
century, 19th century,
18th century economies.
And by 2050, I guarantee
you access to electricity,
to energy for most people on the planet,
will be far less of a
problem than it has ever been
in human history.
And that is the kind of
economic shift that we need.
So encouraging policy makers
and legislators begins
with citizens, empowered
and informed citizens.
It then involves governments
and it recognizes how
central the rules of the
game of our markets are
in driving change or preventing change
- Administrator Steiner, I
have to say your perspective
as an optimist definitely
comes through in the
Human Development Report.
I recall the language
about humans as agents.
Humans, as people that have
the power and the capacity
to produce better for themselves.
And that the goal of human
development really is about
facilitating the conditions
to support human freedom
and autonomy.
And as someone who leads
an agency that works with
170 countries around the
world for poverty eradication
and inclusive society, I wanna ask you,
how could we create strong
partnerships and collaborations
across the world to
fulfill the promise of the
climate agenda while also as we face
the socio-economic crises
that has been triggered
by the COVID-19 pandemic?
What are your thoughts on that?
- Kindly if you would allow
me just a brief remark
on agency, I think it is
a very critical aspect of
the 2020 Human Development Report because,
it's very easy for many
of us in today's world,
the fourth industrial revolution world,
the digitalization world,
artificial intelligence,
everybody talking about
systems complexity,
to feel this empowered.
And I think this is a very
dangerous narrative to pursue.
And that's why in the
Human Development Report,
we tried to put so much attention
on this notion of agency,
the ability to choose, the
capabilities to make choices
that are different from
those that are simply handed
down to us.
And choices really matter.
And in a recent TED talk,
used the analogy that,
systems don't change systems,
people change systems.
And it is very much with that philosophy
or with that paradigm let's
say in mind, that we approach
these important choices that
we have to make right now.
And you asked me about partnerships.
These is to answer this,
the more we work together,
the easier it will be.
I mean, this is the foundational principle
of the United Nations.
in 1945 on the ashes of
the Second World War,
and having learned the bitter
lesson of what happens to a
world that is capable of self destruction,
even more so after the Second World War,
finding both the place,
the space and the ability
to work together despite our differences
clearly is at the heart of
any notion of partnership.
And I would begin when
we have a challenge such
as climate change to remind ourselves that
with all the justified
criticism of 30 years
of climate negotiations,
from the Rio 1992 Summit
through the Copenhagen
Climate Convention Summit
into the Paris Agreement.
And yes, here we are in the year 2021
and time is still running out.
But at the same time,
just imagine for a moment
that we didn't have the
IPCC over 30 years ago,
that kind of rescued
science from the dictum of
national policy and national
interest that allows scientists
to speak to the world
independently about what we knew
and what we didn't know
about what was happening
to our planet.
If you then think of
the climate convention,
do you think we would have
been worse off or better off
if not every year for the
past I think it is now 25
or 26 years, the climate
convention essentially brought
all these countries around
the table once a year
in the limelight of
international attention
and showed up the world's
nations and leaders
for what they were doing or not doing?
I think we reached Paris in 2015
because the public saw how
much was not being done.
And so that partnership
uncomfortable as it is,
even in a very political
world of a G2 world,
China and the US or Europe and Africa,
you can find many reasons
to look at the world being
very divided.
And yet we have a Paris Agreement,
we have a pathway to
raising ambition levels
every five years and
hopefully a possibility
of aligning where the world is acting
with where science is
telling us since years,
we should have acted.
So this is one way of
thinking about partnership.
The other one may be between public sector
and private sector.
And frankly speaking
anybody who thinks that the
private sector does not or
is not needed as a partner
in this enterprise of challenging,
of addressing the challenge
of climate change,
loss of biodiversity, simply
overlooks the fact that most
of the things that happen in
our daily lives are transacted
not through governments, not
through public sector budgets,
but through the private sector.
And the private sector also is not always
corporate multinational, giant companies.
Private sector is the small scale farmer.
It's the corner shop owner.
It's the startup enterprise.
It's the people who produce
most of the world's food today.
Small scale farmers produce over 70%
of the food we consume on the planet.
So the private sector is
essentially that extraordinary
diverse domain that we
need to bring along,
that we need to incentivize
with our consumer choices,
with our public policies, with our laws,
in order to be part of the solution,
rather than part of the problem.
And that is perhaps the
greatest shift in thinking
of our time.
Because remember Milton
Friedman and not so long ago,
that the cradle, the religion
of economic correctness was,
"companies have to think
about their shareholders
and nothing else."
We have come a long way and
we have paid a heavy price
for the time we took
to come this long way.
But I think we are in many
ways at a point in time
where the markets of the future,
on the one hand will drive
new enterprises and
businesses and where the costs
of being rooted in the legacy economy
will simply become prohibitive
and stranded assets suddenly
become a very stark reality.
So that is perhaps a way
of answering partnerships
from multiple perspectives.
- Thank you.
Yeah, thanks as Administrator Steiner.
So now we're getting some
questions from the audience.
So I have a question here.
Actually, you mentioned World War Two.
So the question is, "I wonder
if Administrator Steiner
could talk about a fourth
P, the young people, planet
and prosperity that of peace."
"Could you elaborate on
the relationship between
climate change and
conflict and the importance
of building peace while also
addressing climate change?"
- A very appropriate question.
And in fact, earlier
today I was co-chairing
with my colleague Filippo Grandi
and the Director General
of Humanitarian Affairs
of the Syria Pledging Conference.
Here is a conflict 10 years
old, unimaginable suffering
and tragedy.
It's spill over effects
into neighboring countries
such as Lebanon, Jordan, and Turkey
who are hosting millions of refugees.
And at a moment in time
where their own economies
are imploding.
I mean, you have all seen
the news about Lebanon.
So here is one example
of how peace is not only
a humanitarian catastrophe,
it is also a major setback
in developmental terms.
And the same applies for so
many countries in conflict.
Yemen in which UNDP and
the United Nations family
has now been working
for a number of years,
almost seven years in
another protracted conflict.
We estimate that Yemen
has lost somewhere between
20 to 25 years of its
development in these six years.
Just to give you a sense of
the setback that that conflict
causes.
Now, many of us have heard,
and I think we'll not be
surprised that if climate
change really begins to affect,
many of the things that we take
for granted, when it rains,
when we're able to have
enough water to plant,
floods, the other extreme, but
also temperature variations,
sea level rise, extreme weather events.
The sheer impact on people
and humanity and our economies
that we have seen so
often in recent years,
here in the United States, in
the Caribbean where sometimes
a 24 hour event can wipe
out 30% of your GDP.
This kind of disruption
is absolutely anathema to
peaceful societies and
peaceful development.
That doesn't mean that people
suddenly turn on one another
because of a disaster, but
if we allow these pressures
to continue and if you
do not prepare for them,
then it is quite clear that we
will see many more conflicts
arising whether it is upstream, downstream
water sharing countries on river basins.
Whether it is pastoralists
who have to essentially change
their annual migrations
with their livestock
and are increasingly clashing
resident farming communities.
Whether it is the waves of
migrants who essentially
seen no future in their
countries and at the risk
of their own lives, moving
into other parts of the world,
whether it is central
America to North America,
whether it is Africa to Europe.
These are the kinds of
disruptions that very quickly,
when governance systems don't work well,
when societies are ill
prepared, give rise to tensions,
to conflict, to
radicalization, to extremism
and a very vicious circle unfolds.
And I think another live
illustration of this drama
is what is playing out in the Sahel region
probably for the better part
of the last 20 to 30 years.
And it should look forward
unless we truly step in
and get to the root
causes of this disruption.
We will see a great deal, more conflict
and the absence of peace.
So it is in my mind, very
appropriate that we are seeing
increasingly in the United
Nations, the link established
between climate change,
broader environmental change
and peace and security.
Environmental change is
threatening international
or human security.
There is no doubt in my mind.
The question is, can we
find in the 21st century
collective response that
is not simply rooted
in 20th century or simply
geopolitical conflict
and competitions?
If that is the driving force,
then indeed you will continue
to witness what you often see right now
in the security council
in international fora,
the inability of governments to provide
collective leadership and partnership.
- Thank you.
We have actually many more
questions in the Q&A chat,
and we're gonna be able
to pose to you to answer.
Administrator Steiner, so
professor Dubrow and I will select
ones that we think will be
most interesting for you.
So here's the next one.
"Will you talk a little bit
more about the intersection
of environmental justice
and planetary health
with other systems of oppression,
that disproportionately
impact identity groups,
for example the plight of
Gullah Geechee land sustainability in the
Gullah Geechee quarter
of the United States.
The Gullah Geechee are people
who are descendants of slaves,
who've lived along the South
Carolina and South Georgia
coastal areas.
And I think that land is,
there's trouble with seizing
the land for development.
So this person is asking,
can you talk a little bit
more about how those justice
and planetary health systems intersect?
- Thank you for this question.
That is one that takes up a
significant amount of time
in my thinking that I think
of many of us who work in UNDP
because whether it is
through the reality of race,
whether it is through poverty and wealth,
whether it is through the gender lens,
inequalities amplify the
impact of the kinds of changes,
environmental changes and
impacts that I have described.
I earlier mentioned just
the the example of lead
and air pollution and how,
just by virtue of your income,
your children very often
would be worse effected
because of where you have to live.
Now race clearly introduces
in many societies,
another dimension of either discrimination
or simply of inadvertently
being more vulnerable,
more exposed to the impacts of change.
Now, I don't know the particular
example that the question
raised just now, but clearly
race has played a part
in the United States for instance,
most dramatically
illustrated during COVID-19.
But if you also look at
the basic health data
and health statistics
across countries such as
the United States, but indeed
other countries as well,
more often than not, there is a parameter,
there is a pattern in which
racial differentiation
allows you to recognize
very differential impacts.
And so I think understanding
the environmental impacts,
which are often transacted in
terms of scientific indicators
and indices, they need
to be complimented by
let's say more social criteria,
because it allows us to see,
not just the physicality of
what we're talking about,
but the social reality.
And that's where the notion
of justice becomes so real.
Now, justice is involved in many ways.
There is injustice that is
associated with inequality.
There is injustice that is discrimination
and there is injustice
simply with negligence
that is often associated
with the way that,
governments and societies,
well, at its simplest really
care about all of their
citizens.
Look at our world today.
Access to vaccines is
primarily and principally
at this moment in time in the year 2021
a function of how much money
you have, or you do not have.
This is the 21st century in
which we are, still imprisoned
by such a crude way of
dealing with something
that fundamentally offends
our sense of justice
and fairness.
Now you can take it very
quickly to climate justice.
For example, speaking in
an intergenerational sense
I think to me, what
Fridays For Future did more
than anything else, was to
remind me of how privileged I am
that I still have the
choice to do something
about climate change,
while perhaps my sons
or their children will not
even have the choice anymore.
So here is a fundamental
issue of justice that again,
I think defines the way
we need to understand
our responsibility to act.
And then there is just transitional also.
Let me give you a dilemma
that just a few weeks ago
I was addressing with a vice president
and the advisory council
of an African nation
which was basically trying
to look at how to build
forward better from COVID-19.
And it's a country that
has discovered oil,
that has still gas reserves,
and that essentially pose
the question to me,
"so where is the just transition for us?"
"Because for us not drilling
and not exporting these
fossil fuel resources
is almost unexplainable
to our citizens."
So if we were to take a step back,
if he were to actually take a leap forward
into the green economy,
invest in renewables
and perhaps not exploit 50%
of our fossil fuel reserves,
where's the justice in
that when essentially
industrialized world has spent 200 years
and the United States just
in the last four years
was the world's largest
producer of oil and gas.
I mean let us remind ourselves,
the largest carbon dioxide
emitter over the last 200 years
taken collectively, cumulatively,
also was the country
that became the largest oil
producer in the last four years.
So if you are a small African economy,
where is the just transition
that was promised as part
of this global climate policy
in this world of today?
And this is why and what
we do in the United Nations
whether it's the convention,
whether it's UNDP
whether it's the United
Nations Environment Program,
we try to address this
injustice by finding ways
in which a more just
transition becomes possible.
And the same can be
extrapolated right back
to a local community.
If you have grown up in
a coal mining community
and tomorrow, somebody
tells you, "it's over."
You're not just dealing
with shutting a mine,
you may find, 20,000 jobs for the people,
you're essentially killing
a community in the way that
it has seen and identified
itself for decades sometimes.
It's not just money
that buys justice here,
it's a different sense of what
a just transition could mean
to that community.
So let me stop here but
I think it's a topic
that is extremely important
and if we fail or succeed
in really meeting the climate challenge,
I think it will largely
be as a result of finding
the right answers to this issue, namely,
"what is a just transition."
- Thank you.
- Yeah, thanks Administrator Steiner.
So we have time for one more question
and probably a fairly short answer.
So the question is with the
goal of enabling ordinary people
to realize their individual
and personal aspirations
themselves, how can
science be made more useful
as a tool for use by ordinary people?
- Now, as somebody who has
never brilliant at school
in the sciences, I'm not
sure I'm the best person
to answer that question.
But let me perhaps share with
you a simple lesson in life.
And, since I now lead an
organization that has 18,000 people
to who I'm answerable, to
who I also have to sound
intelligent enough to be
able to listen to good
scientific advice.
I think we need to recognize that,
in one person you will
never find everything.
Whether it is scientific
knowledge or whether it is wisdom
or whether it is
perspective for that matter.
It is how you bring people together
and how you make collective thinking,
collective intelligence work.
And how you're able to listen
to science, not as a dictate,
because science also really
doesn't answer questions.
It provides you input that
information in order for us to do
what makes us as a human
species, so unique.
We can process information,
we can essentially
assimilate facts and then we make choices.
We can make judgment calls.
Now, sometimes those calls
are almost mathematical
and the answer is very simple.
Two plus two is four.
But most of the time in
life, I think the thing that
I have learned is that
science provides me with
a reference point.
Sometimes, yes, if it's antibiotics,
it's also a very simple treatment.
But for most of the things
that we are trying to deal with
in terms of sustainable development,
the future of development in
this age of the Anthropocene,
science is only one dimension of it.
And I think we have to accept that,
science is a field that is
constantly growing exponentially
just like with digitalization
and technology,
and therefore specialization
is critical and not all of us,
most of us can be those specialists.
So the question is how
do we create processes
in our society, where
science continues to inform
our thinking and doesn't
disenfranchise us.
And this is not an easy
moment because scientists
know a hell of a lot, and
certainly know a great deal more
than many of us, but
they don't necessarily
get the right to decide for us.
So it is both for the scientists
to find ways in which to
engage with society about the
knowledge that they generate
and are privileged
enough to have developed
on our collective behalf.
And it is for us to look
for fora in which we can
transact science.
And at the end of the day, I
go back to where we started
this afternoon which is, we
talk about planetary health,
to some of this sounds
incredibly complicated
and yet a lot of it is just common sense.
And what we are doing
with science is informing
and empowering people
to exercise common sense
with the best possible
information at our disposal.
And that kind of slightly
shifts the terms of power here,
because there is the temptation
for science to become almost
a kind of separate universe
of decision making.
I think that is not an
interest either of science
nor of society.
And I hope that that is
perhaps a way of approaching
an answer.
It certainly isn't adequate
answer to the question.
- Well, yeah, no, that was a great answer.
Thank you.
And unfortunately there's
this whole question
that's developed with the
anti-vaccination et cetera
that we won't have time to get into today,
but it's another important
area related to science.
But our time has come to an end.
So I wanted to thank you
Administrator Steiner
for really fantastic conversations today.
I'd also like to thank
LaRon for co-moderating,
Dean Kurth for our welcoming
remarks and you the audience
for your engaging and
insightful questions.
So thank you all for joining us today.
And we look forward to
seeing you at the next event
of the YIGH Global Health
Conversation series.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Great to have you.